- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(gentle electronic keyboard music)
- I'm William Lester,
professor of chemistry
and Chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We're pleased, along with the
Graduate Council to present
Dr. Sylvia Earle, this years speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
As a condition of this bequest,
we're obligated and happy
to tell you how the endowment
came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to
the history of California
and the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the Army,
came to San Francisco
during the gold rush,
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1895 Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley, as an expression
of his long held interest in education.
His daughter, Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become one
of the most cherished endowments
of the University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you Lillie, Charles,
and now a few words about Dr. Earle.
World renowned marine
scientist, Dr. Sylvia Earle,
is president of the Sea Alliance,
a non-profit whose mission
is to create awareness
of the ocean's importance to all life,
explore global waters, and
inspire conservative action.
In 1992 she founded Deep
Ocean Exploration and Research
which pioneers technologies
for scientific ocean
research and exploration.
The company presently
is owned and operated
by Elizabeth Taylor and Ian Griffith,
who are working with Dr.
Earle to develop technologies
for working access to full ocean depth.
Through Mission Blue,
Dr. Earle, Sea Alliance,
and a growing number
of partners are working
to establish Hope Sports,
regions rich in marine bio-diversity,
that with protection can
help restore areas damaged
by human activities and natural disasters.
Early in her career,
Earle led the first
team of women aquanauts
during the Tektite Project.
Among several diving records,
she was the first person to dive solo
to a depth of 1,250 feet
without being connected
to a support vessel.
Dr. Earle has authored
more than 80 publications,
has led a hundred expeditions worldwide,
and logged over 7,000 hours underwater
in connection with her research.
She is an explorer in residence
at the National Geographic Society
and was the US National Oceanic
and Atmospheric
Administrations chief scientist
from 1990 to 1992.
Earle received her BS from
Florida State University in 1955,
and her MA and PhD from Duke University
in 1956 and 1966 respectively.
In addition, Dr. Earle
has been awarded 20 honorary degrees.
Dr. Earle has been awarded numerous honors
for her extensive and
illuminating work in oceanography.
She is a recipient of
the Netherlands Order
of the Golden Ark and is a member
of the National Women's Hall of Fame,
and the American Academy of Achievement.
In addition, Earle has received medals
from the Explorer's Club,
the Lindbergh Foundation,
the National Wildlife Federation,
and the National Parks
Conservation Association.
She received the 2009 TED Prize
and the 2011 Royal Geographical
Society Patron's Medal.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Earle.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you for the grand
introduction, very small edits.
First it's conservation,
not conservative, (laughing)
although the roots are the much the same.
If you want to be a conservationist,
you really want to take care
and protect the wild world,
and keep things in good shape.
Nothing wrong with that.
The other was, Hope Sports,
which I think is a great idea,
but it's really Hope Spots. (laughing)
And by that I mean places
like the Grand Canyon,
like Yellowstone, like the
National Park System as a whole.
But in the ocean, we have been lacking
the kind of protection that
over much of the 20th century
has grown into, globally
about 12% of the land
invested in some way to protect nature.
In the ocean we're lagging far behind
with a tiny fraction of 1%,
where even the fish are safe.
About 1% overall that is
protected with some kind
of management regime,
such as here in California
with the new network of
protected areas along the coast
and the four marine sanctuaries,
National Marine Sanctuaries,
including the Farallones just offshore,
Cordell Bank just up the coast a bit,
and of course Monterey Bay
National Marine Sanctuary,
that goes far beyond Monterey Bay.
It's about 5,000 square miles of ocean.
But sanctuary is perhaps
not the right term to use
for any of these or the Channel Islands
National Marine Sanctuary
because the squid aren't safe,
the herring aren't safe,
the crabs aren't safe.
We exploit them inside
and outside the sanctuary
with about the same degree of latitude
with overarching policies,
but it's time that we look
at the ocean with new eyes, new respect.
That's primarily what
I'm going to focus on
during this first of two opportunities
to sound off about a
number of things with you.
Actually this is not my
first time on campus.
My first time goes back to 1966,
before most of you were born.
I had a chance to work with people
in the Botany Department
here and from others who were interested
in the marine plants, the algae,
the macro-algae that
live in great abundance
along the rocky shores of California
and off into deep water beyond.
We started up close to the northern edge
of the California border
and worked our way
over the coastline, down to pretty close
to the southern border of California.
Camping along the way, gathering
samples of as many kinds
of creatures as we could
find by just snorkeling
and looking along the beach.
We did not have diving equipment
available to us at that time.
We've learned so much, so fast
during the decades that have followed.
I actually spent some time on campus here,
working on what was my dissertation,
preparing it for publication
in (giggling) 1967, 1968.
The publication actually came out in 1969.
Some of you will perhaps
remember the state of the world
during that era, when,
I remember driving onto campus.
It would've been about 1968, 69,
and there was tear gas all over the place,
and I felt a little bit insulted
that they were stopping people,
not letting them come on
campus, but they let me through.
I mean, what was it about
me that made me okay,
when some of my pals,
they said no they wouldn't let them on.
Well I'm glad they let me come on campus,
because I holed up and worked
in the Botany Department
looking at the great
collection of marine algae
that is housed here.
Most of you probably don't
even know that it exists,
but it's one of the best
collections in the world.
It documents the history
of the kinds of creatures,
the plants at least that live in the ocean
over long periods of
time, before the present,
collected by people who
have used the herbarium
in the Botany Department as a repository
for this great historic
record of how things were
and how things are, as a guide
to imagining how they
might be going forward.
It's a critical part of
being alive right now,
to reflect on how fast
things have changed.
Not just in 40 or 50 years,
and not thinking geologically,
of course things have changed over time,
but even in the last 10 years.
The pace is picking up of how
the world, the natural world
is feeling the influence
of what we're doing to it.
We could see it on the
land and Rachel Carson
wrote in The Sea Around
Us, in 1951, about what,
sort of the distillation of what was known
concerning the oceans of the
world for the popular audience,
but scientifically sound.
One of the great science writers
who laced the scientific facts
with a good deal of poetic presentation
that made it accessible
to the public at large.
In 1951, 10 years before the Silent World,
the, excuse me, The Silent
Spring was published.
Silent World, Cousteau's beginning of,
in terms of communicating
with the public was 1952.
This was a time when, we
just were beginning to think
about what was under the
surface of the ocean.
Plate tectonics was not,
not known at that time.
I mean I think there was some people
who thought maybe the
continents moved around,
no mechanism was identified
though in the 1950's.
Now it's a major scientific endeavor,
a whole study, geo-science
of plate tectonics,
looking at how the
continents have moved around,
how the sea floor has spread over time.
We've learned more about
the ocean literally,
since the mid-50's, then during all
preceding human history put together.
And at the same time, I
think it's fair to say
that more has changed, because since then
about half the coral
reefs around the world
have either disappeared
or they have been affected negatively.
I mean there in a state of great decline.
In the Caribbean, it's
about 80% of the coral reefs
are gone since the 1950's,
since the 1950's for heaven's sake,
half a century plus a bit.
What we've done to the fish
in the sea because we love to eat them
and now we know how to catch them in ways
that fish just aren't prepared
for our means of finding, and
extracting, and shipping them
all over the world.
This is new on the horizon.
90% more or less of many of the fish
that we love to consume,
the tunas, the swordfish,
the sharks, the creatures
that once did not have humans
as predators, now we
are the principle source
of their decline.
It's true with so many kinds
of creatures in the sea.
We knew, going back to the
beginning of the 20th century,
that we had the power to greatly reduce
the number of marine mammals in the sea.
At the time whales, and seals,
and sea lions, and otters
were primarily thought of as commodities,
and it's hard in today's perspective
to imagine a time as recently as 1972,
when the Richmond Whaling
Station was still,
well that was the year it closed,
but it was open until then,
taking humpback whales
for dog food, for pet food,
for oil, for fertilizer.
Now we understand.
We understood even early
in the 20th century
that we had the power to greatly
reduce wildlife in the sea,
even using relatively modest techniques.
Fortunately for whales and for us,
we realized that while we have
the power to eliminate them,
and they are valuable as commodities,
that we also have the power to
protect them, and since 1986
commercial whaling around the world has,
a moratorium exists.
That has been good news for gray whales,
good news for humpback whales,
good news for most whales.
Hasn't turned things
around for some species,
but the general theme is pretty obvious.
If you stop killing them,
they might begin to recover.
We haven't learned that with fish.
We're still, still on a downward spiral
of taking too much of the
wild creatures in the sea
and haven't really faced up to the reality
that if we really want to
have tunas, and swordfish,
and sharks, and many other
creatures in the ocean,
we've got to stop killing
them for heaven's sakes.
There are other ways
we can feed ourselves,
and maybe we can get by with taking a few.
But the commercial
exploitation of ocean wildlife,
now we know that there are real limits,
and we've exceeded those limits
on most of the kinds of things
that we like to take
from the sea presently.
So what to do about it?
It's hard to bring about overnight changes
on anything of consequence,
but some change,
some places in the sea.
If we can establish them for protection
as has been done here in California,
with this little network
of fully protected areas, marine reserves.
Where it has happened, good news occurs.
The fish in very short period of time,
two or three years, begin to recover.
You get greater diversity.
You get larger numbers.
You get larger fish.
Like, duh, you stop
killing them. (laughing)
It's a first step toward recovery.
There are other things that we can do.
You need to protect breeding
areas, feeding areas.
You can't compete with them,
as we are in Antarctica,
competing with not just
whales, but the whole system,
by taking the krill in large numbers.
Well, much of,
what I'm addressing right now,
is something that we have
just began to face up to
since I arrived on the planet.
Awareness that unlike the
attitude that shaped our policies
formed in the 1950's, and
60's, and 70's, and even today,
based on this feeling that
the ocean is so big, so vast,
so resilient, that there's nothing much
that we puny human beings
can do to alter its nature.
But now we know that it's different.
We do have the power to
alter the skies above
with excess carbon dioxide
driving climate change.
Global warming, and now
acidification of the oceans
with excess CO2 turning to carbon dioxide,
to carbonic acid, creating
bad news for things
with a calcium carbonate
shell of the little creatures
that do much of the heavy
lifting in the ocean,
generating oxygen, grabbing carbon,
bad news for coral reefs.
Who knows what problems
are being caused right now
because of this trend
toward acidification.
But the good news is, now we
know what we could not know
50, 60, 100, 1,000 years
ago, now it's confirmed.
We have the power to alter
the nature of nature.
Now we know that our lives
depend on these natural systems
for things we've always
heretofore taken for granted,
like do you like to breathe?
I mean where do you
think oxygen comes from.
It doesn't just magically
pop into the air.
It is generated by photosynthesis,
those green things on the land,
the green and blue-green
creatures in the sea,
largely bacteria that
generate much of the oxygen
in every breath we take.
And the water-cycle, the carbon-cycle,
the whatever it is, is governed
largely because there is
an ocean out there that
we haven't had to take
conscious actions to
protect until about now.
One of the things that
gives me cause for hope
is that much has been learned
about the sea in my lifetime.
I think the most important thing perhaps
may be the magnitude of our ignorance,
that only about 5% of
the ocean has been seen,
let alone explored, let alone
put on the balance sheet
in terms of okay this how
it relates back to us.
But we know enough to know that
if the ocean is in trouble,
we're in trouble, and we
also know enough to know
that we have the power to
take actions to stabilize
some of these trends
that are so worrisome.
And one of the things that can be done,
just as on the land,
is to protect the engine that works,
protect the natural
systems that have developed
through all preceding history,
and do no harm to them.
Keep them intact.
Do what we can to restore
what we can of the systems
that keep the engine running in our favor.
And so, when I was given
an opportunity in 2009
by the TEDsters, this
organization that originated
in this area, well Silicon Valley.
It started about 26 or 27 years ago,
where a group of people got together,
and it was kind of an
intimate group to start with,
a little brain trust of people
who began discussing issues
and thinking about what they
could do to use their powers
to maybe leave the world a better place.
It grew, and it grew, and it grew,
and it became something
of a phenomenon that you
may now know as TED, just T-E-D,
but it's Technology,
Entertainment, Design,
and now has moved to southern California
because a bigger space was
required and they operate it now
out of Long Beach.
And now the way they tend
to generate their activity
is to invite individuals that they choose
from anywhere in the world to come,
basically give the talk of their life
and to cram it into 18 minutes flat.
I mean the door opens
and you fall through it
after 18 minutes and 10 seconds.
So I had been on the
outside wanting to go attend
the TED Talks, I never got to do it,
and I really did want
to have an opportunity
to you know, give the talk of my world,
of my life that could be
spread around the world.
That's the other thing, TED
uses the new media now available
to take these 18 minute
messages and make them available
in the new ways that we
can, that didn't exist,
not even 10 years ago but now do,
as a megaphone to take
these messages far and wide.
So I got the call from Chris Anderson
who is the backer, he calls
himself the curator of TED, to,
I said, I'm gonna be asked to
give a talk, and yes I was.
I was asked to give a
talk, but it was more.
I was told that I had been
awarded the TED Prize.
Now the TED Prize is a bit of money,
but most importantly it is
they grant you a wish, huh.
If somebody said we'll grant you a wish,
like the fairy godmother
comes in and says bunk.
Okay but it can't be something little,
it has to be a wish big
enough to change the world.
Well for me that was pretty easy,
I knew what I wanted to wish right away.
Cramming that into 18 minutes
was the real challenge,
and articulating it in such a way
that maybe people would buy into the idea,
to think that yeah this
is kind of important,
that maybe we should think
about taking care of the ocean
that takes care of us.
And how do you do that?
Lots of different ways.
But I said we need to ignite
public support awareness
by harnessing the internet,
harnessing whatever media exists
by furthering research and exploration,
new technologies to explore
and understand the ocean.
But fundamentally we
need to protect the ocean
in a physical, tangible way
by having protected areas,
something that California has pioneered
but we need it to go a lot
further to make this happen.
And when you think, here's the world
and a fraction of 1% of
it is safe for the life
that lives in the ocean,
that drives the way the world works,
what an opportunity to come
along at this point in history,
at the beginning of the 21st century,
to do for the oceans what those pioneers
early in the 20th
century did for the land,
the idea that some said was
the best idea America ever had,
the National Park System.
But we need this not
just for this country,
but for the world to protect the assets,
to protect our life support system,
and now we have some
new tools to do it with,
to share the view, to
provide the rationale,
to do what we couldn't
do when I was a kid,
couldn't do even 20 years
ago, couldn't do 10 years ago,
with that wonderful
platform called Google Earth
and underlying that
the scientific basis information
that ESRI, the E-S-R-I,
the organization based here in California,
that gathers information,
knit-stitches the information together,
and presents it in a
way so that ecologists
have new insights, anybody, city managers,
kids, CEO's, leaders of countries.
So I'm going to take you on a quick tour,
using not only Google Earth,
but the Ocean in Google Earth.
- [Narrator] Come along on
a tour with Mission Blue,
an organization founded by Sylvia Earle
that is dedicated to exploring
and caring for the ocean.
On this tour we'll visit
some special places
called Hope Spots, that
are critical to the health
of the ocean, the blue
heart of the planet.
- [Sylvia] It's the
coolest image in the world,
of the world. (laughing)
I mean I came along years ago,
before this image was possible.
Kids now take it for granted,
that yes now we know, the world is round.
There's a time not so long ago
when that was still a matter of debate.
Well it's not quite
round, we know that now.
Now you can, with your
cell phone, your iPad,
your computer, whatever you like,
you can do this.
You can fly to Baja California, dive in,
get a look at the creatures
who live under water.
The engineers at Google
had a couple of challenges
in transforming Google Earth
so that you could actually
dive in beneath the surface.
First of all, they could
go from the stars above,
down to the surface, and
fly around Grand Canyon,
see your backyard, and
your neighbor's back yard,
find Starbucks, and do
all sorts of things.
The one thing they couldn't
do was go underwater
and they didn't know how to
portray the surface of the water
so you knew when you were above or below,
but as you can see they kind
of solved that problem now.
And you can do what is done
here in a little snapshot,
of create your own tour of
Google Earth, Google Ocean,
and there are ways to
upload your photographs
to share with the rest of the world,
to actually use this as a node,
a way to understand better
what's happening around the world.
And anybody can be a vicarious explorer,
to see places, to see creatures,
to personally connect the
dots and look for patterns.
This is like an atlas that's alive,
and the changes can change every day,
and over time I think we'll have a role
in sensitizing people
to the need to take care
of this system that really is vital
to our survival, our well-being,
to go to places such as you see here
off in the Coral Triangle,
the western Pacific,
where the greatest diversity
of corals, and coral reef fish,
and echinoderms, and many
categories of ocean creatures
have their highest
level of diversity here,
but it's at risk right now from fishing,
from coastal development, from ignorance.
Largely, people don't
know, so they can't care.
Not everybody is going to be
able to zip down to Antarctica
to take a look at what's happening there,
but again, vicariously you can do this.
You can see how the ice is retreating
and make the connection,
make the link back
to well why is it so quickly disappearing,
in the Arctic as well,
and to understand what's
beneath the surface
like the Gakkel Ridge
under the Arctic Ocean,
that the existence of this
wasn't known when I was a kid.
Now we know that it's there.
Now we know about the existence
of hydro-thermal vents
in places throughout
the oceans of the world.
The best hope for the
future is really in knowing.
You can't care if you don't know,
and we haven't known so
much about why nature,
why the ocean, why fish alive matter.
And so we've done some
really stupid things
in the past through ignorance,
but now there's no excuse
for not taking care of these things,
that we don't know how
to put back together
again once they're gone.
So watch this.
Again that image, you know that associated
one way or the other with
the National Geographic
ever since I was a kid.
I mean first of all we
used to subscribe to it.
Our house in New Jersey
was kind of tilted in this direction.
The Geographics were on the downside.
We can't throw them away, I
still can't throw them away.
They occupy a big part
of what of what I call
home over in Oakland.
But I first had a chance
to make a contribution
to the National Geographic in 1971
and at they time when they
asked me if I would write
an article about living underwater,
my first reaction as an
ivory tower scientist
and at Harvard, it was actually
1970 when they asked me,
I said no, because scientists don't write
for the popular press, if
they do they cross the line.
Even the National Geographic,
as distinguished and beloved as it is,
at the time for me was,
you know as a scientist it would've put me
in a different category and
I wrestled with the idea
of whether I should write
for the National
Geographic after I said no.
And what caused me to eventually say yes
and write my first article
was a curious coincidence.
On my shelf there's a little
book by Thomas Huxley called,
On Discourses, Geological and Biological,
where he has a collection of essays.
The first essay was to
the carpenter's union
in Norwich, England, and
he took a piece of chalk
out of his pocket, and he
describes this in his essay,
and showed it to the
carpenters, and pointed out
that here was the history
of the North Atlantic Ocean
written in the creatures
that were in the chalk.
And he had a way, he
entranced me a hundred years
after this book was published,
and it was the beginning
of the book though.
In the introduction he
said, as a scientist
your fellow scientists will scorn you
for speaking to the public,
but you must do it as a
scientist to give back,
and the one thing you
must do is tell the truth,
and don't give in to the
temptation to embellish.
That I now know, it's the kiss of death,
and that's probably why
the scientific community
has over the years become
resistant to the idea
of communicating because
often communicating
with other then their learned colleagues,
the truth gets stretched, and
stories get passed around,
and it's not what you said,
it's what others want to believe.
But I was motivated to give in
and write my first article
for the National Geographic,
and I was impressed by the scrutiny
that they put me through, more
than any peer review journal
that I've ever, ever written for,
and I mean I did cross the line,
and I did lose some ground I
suppose as a learned scientist
among my colleagues, but
now it's somewhat different.
Now I think in part, because scientists
are really having a hard time
being appreciated as, and science.
It's not the scientist
it's the science that is,
we need to become better
communicators, whatever it takes,
and now we have new tools to do it,
and now the National Science Foundation,
and other granting institutions,
not only encourage you to do it,
in some cases they really
mandate that you find some way
to communicate beyond just
the usual scientific journals.
I hope this is good news
because we need science-based policy.
We need science-based
conservation for heaven sakes.
We need to understand the reality
to the best of our ability,
and to get the public
generally to appreciate
what we know, and what they need to know.
So, this is a picture that
the National Geographic
had nothing to do with developing,
but it's still perhaps the best image
that has ever been taken,
in terms of something that
will make a difference
in the way people regard themselves.
I've also come along,
not just during this time
of great new means of communicating,
but also new ways of exploring the ocean.
I had the fun of being
one of the first people
in the country to try scuba, it was 1953.
I was taking one of the first classes
taught in the country in Marine Biology.
It was at Florida State University.
We had two scuba tanks.
I had two words of
instruction, breathe naturally,
(audience laughing)
and it's really important to do that.
Don't hold your breath (chuckling)
while you're going up and
down in the water column,
and it kept us alive, and later we learned
a lot of other things that we
needed to do to stay alive.
I think it's fantastic,
wonderful, a blessing,
that we have now developed new
means of exploring the ocean,
and there are millions of people
who have taken the plunge,
put on a mask and flippers,
a tank, been able to go down
to 50 meters or so beneath the surface,
get acquainted with the
blue part of the planet.
This little blue speck in
the universe that is special.
I've had a chance to live underwater
on nine different occasions.
This is the most recent
underwater laboratory
in existence, the Aquarius.
It was launched more than 20 years ago.
It's still working away down
in the Florida Keys and I mean,
you can submit a project and
perhaps do what they call,
be an aquanaut.
I got to be an aquanaut first in 1970
for the Tektite Project, living
underwater for two weeks.
At first they didn't know
whether women would be allowed
to participate, because
they hadn't thought to say
no women should apply, but
when a number of us did,
and the projects, and our qualifications
seemed to be pretty good,
the head of the program
made history of the sort,
Jim Miller, who had a
happy marriage I think,
and had a good mom, 'cause he said,
well shall there or
shall there not be women.
Well half the fish are female,
I guess we could put up with a few women,
and they did, they put up with us.
They couldn't put us together
with our male colleagues
because, and the words
they used at the time were,
there could be hanky-panky on the reef.
(audience laughing)
I mean hanky-panky, what
kind of word is that.
But anyway, they made an all women's team
and it turned out to be a media feast.
The idea of women, a team of women,
mere women living
underwater for two weeks.
And there were 50 men and women
over a period of that year, 1970,
that stayed for 10 days to
as much as two full months
living underwater, but I was one of the,
our team, the women's
team stayed for two weeks,
and we got wonderful questions such as,
did you wear lipstick underwater?
Did you use a hairdryer?
I mean like, okay we
answered those questions
to this amazing amount of
interest that was generated.
We had a ticker tape parade
down State Street in Chicago,
the women's team, not the
guys, just the women's team.
I got to address Congress and tell about
what it was like to live underwater.
We were treated more or
less the way the astronauts
were treated in the early days.
I mean it sounded kind of
similar, astronaut, aquanaut,
and it was perhaps a
good thing for the ocean.
That' the only basis on
which I could kind of stand
to look at all these microphones
that scared me to death
with the idea of speaking not
just to a group like this,
but like 25 million people out there
on one of the broadcasts
that came after the Tektite Project.
But that was for me,
that and the National
Geographic beating on my door,
saying would you please write an article,
ever since then I've been
beating on their door,
saying please may I write
an article for your magazine
about this, that, or something else.
This is amazing time that we live in,
time that we share, for the
first time kind of understanding
how the whole system, not just
a little piece here or there,
but to really pull the
whole system together,
and understand what we're doing to it,
and how in the next 10 years,
we have an opportunity to
literally make history,
one way or the other, through
what we do or fail to do.
'Cause we're so close to losing.
We're so close to
gaining an enduring place
for ourselves within the natural world
that keeps us alive.
So part of it is having the
tools to get out and explore.
I, in 1979 had a chance to use this suit.
I'll talk about it a little
bit more tomorrow night
when we talk more about technology.
But it seems so primitive in a way,
to just go down and
walk around a thousand,
1,200 feet beneath the surface.
We can go 1,200 feet every other direction
with no real issue, but
imagine just going a thousand,
2,000, 5,000 feet under
the surface of the ocean.
It's still a big deal.
But I love the new technologies
that have come along
just in recent years.
Little submersibles that
are so simple to drive
that even a scientist can
do it, and I'm living proof.
Getting in like a little sports car
and take off 2,000 feet
down beneath the surface,
or another version of the Deep Rover,
that I actually started three companies,
but the first one was to
try to develop systems
that would take scientists down
to explore the ocean personally,
and that goes to a thousand meters.
This is the two person
version of the Deep ORCA
that's built up in Canada.
There are about 20 of these systems,
single and dual deep worker systems.
It's not quite enough to
be like Hertz-Rent-A-Sub,
but it's getting there.
You know, it's maybe in a few years
it will be kind of like that.
So you want to spend a Saturday afternoon
going off to Monterey, not
just diving along the beach,
in the Kelp Forest.
That's really cool and I love
it, but there's a difference.
If you go down to a hundred feet,
you can still see kelps, you
can still see the sea lions,
and the otters, but go
down to a thousand feet,
and it's not that far, a thousand feet.
The place is owned by echinoderms.
There are basket stars.
There are brittle stars.
The place is just alive with
another group of animals
that you don't see at all on the land
or in fresh water,
they're only in the ocean,
and oh are there ever a lot of them,
and they're beautiful,
and they're important.
But what do we know about them?
What does the average
person who lives in Monterey
know about the starfish
that live a mile offshore
and a thousand feet down?
Practically nothing.
It is changing, because
we now have aquariums
like the Monterey Aquarium,
the best in the world,
and of course the Steinhart Aquarium,
it's one of the oldest in the world,
and down on Pier 39
there's this great aquarium
that brings in I thinks something
like 2 million visitors a
year, a halfway house for fish
and people to get
acquainted in ways other,
you know a lot of people see fish
swimming with lemon slices and butter.
But seeing them swimming in
an aquarium or best of all,
go down in the ocean,
go deep in the ocean.
Here's the irony, here we are
with this great space program.
Yeah it's cutting back a bit, but still.
You know we've been to the
moon, we have sent probes
out beyond our own solar system,
but we only have a handful of vehicles
that can go as much as
half the ocean's depth.
This is one the two Mir
subs that Russia owns.
Actually they have three subs now
that can go to 6,000 meters.
France has one, Japan has
one that goes to 6,500.
India is building one to go that deep.
China is building one
to go to 7,000 meters.
But nobody's building something
to go to full ocean depth,
that is to 11,000 meters except
through private initiative.
Not governments, but
we have Richard Branson
and Jim Cameron, private
individuals with their own money
backing something to push the envelope,
to be able to solve the problem,
that actually was solved
with government funding
going back to 1960, when
the Trieste made a dive
to the deepest part of the
ocean once for 20 minutes.
But once you get there what do you see?
Coral reefs, sponge reefs, life,
from the surface to the greatest depths,
critters everywhere.
Every drop of water, Craig Venter,
with his great project
on the human genome,
now has turned his attention to the sea,
looking kind of at the
genome of the ocean,
looking at how many of
what kind of microbes
live in a spoonful of water,
spoonfuls of water being
taken all over the world,
and finding the enormous diversity of life
at the microbial level that
we didn't even know existed
going back to when I was a
kid, or even 20 years ago.
What else is out there, down there?
That we are just beginning to explore
now that we have tools to get
there, to try to understand
what is, what are starfish worth?
I don't mean in terms of
pounds of starfish meat,
but what are they doing?
What are sponges doing for the ocean
and how does all this relate back to us?
It's like Aldo Leopold said
about the diversity of life,
the nuts, the bolts, the cogs, the wheels
that hold the world together.
Which ones can we afford to lose?
Probably none, at least
at our risk do we lose
diverse creatures that each
has a role, a place in the sea,
in making the way the
world functions as it does.
Right now most people, if
they think about squid at all,
they think calamari.
Even here in California,
where there's a somewhat
more enlightened attitude
about life in general then
in many parts of the world,
it's open season on squid, and yet,
if you look at the ocean and how it works,
the last creatures we would
want to kill would be the squid.
They're the middle-men,
low on the food chain,
that are so important to
birds, to seals, to sea lions,
to otters, to fish, to the
chemistry of the ocean.
Food chains that result
every step of the way,
taking food in, putting nutrients out
that drive the phytoplankton,
that drive the food chain,
that drive the oxygen cycle,
that drive the carbon cycle,
that drive the way the world works.
We need this engine to
function for our sake.
I mean I am a squid-hugger.
I love squid, they're
just such great animals.
I've had many encounters with them,
where they get probably frustrated
with humans who look at them.
They go through all this repertoire
of changing their colors, and shapes.
And it's true with octopuses,
and all the cephalopods are
just amazing in their ability
to communicate with color, and
perhaps with bioluminescence,
and we can't do that.
We probably look like idiots out there,
all we can do is bubble.
They go through this
extravagant messaging system
and we just bubble back.
To many water, lakes,
rivers, streams, the ocean
is just that, just water,
but now we know that water,
wherever it is in nature
is likely to be alive.
Well we don't know about Mars, or Jupiter,
or elsewhere in the
universe where water exists,
in some cases in abundance.
Comets, loaded with water, frozen water,
but earth is blessed with lots of water
and with lots of life.
Liquid water is the key and we treat it
as if its ours first
of all, water is ours.
We pipe it, we use it for agriculture,
we use it for all sorts of purposes,
but the most importance use for water
is that it's home for
most of life on earth.
Perhaps 97% of life on earth
is out there in the ocean.
It keeps us alive, shapes
the way the world works,
and until we face up to it
and the need to protect it,
our lives are on the line, at risk.
I love going out and
diving with whale sharks.
It's fairly recently that
I've had a chance to do that
because only recently have
we identified a few places
in the world where they do congregate.
Now pretty reliably you
can go to Baja California,
you can go off Cancun, you
could go a hundred miles south
of the Mississippi Delta,
out into the Gulf of Mexico,
and find yourself in the midst
of gaggles of whale sharks feeding.
You have to first of all
find out where the food is
and then you're likely to find out
where the whale sharks gather.
And off the west coast of Australia
at certain times of the year,
whale sharks get together.
And mostly they're solitary,
but when there's food around
nobody knows yet where
they go to whoop it up
and do what it takes to
make more whale sharks,
the breeding areas, still a mystery.
But one thing we do know is that
when they take a big gulp of plankton,
they're taking a gulp of a
cross-section of life on earth.
The larval stages of so many
of the creatures in the sea,
maybe a dozen phyla of
animals go down the guzzle
of a whale shark with every gulp.
It's astonishing the diversity
of life that's out there
in the water itself.
So when they put a desal
plant in and take in water,
it isn't just water.
It's a soup, it's a living soup.
You sacrifice all the little
guys that are in the water
going in to get fresh water and salt
coming out the other end,
and that doesn't mean that
we shouldn't be doing this,
but we should do it with our eyes open,
and consider the trade-offs.
Be careful and maybe get
smarter about how we deal
with water as a commodity,
and fish as a commodity.
Huh, living underwater,
that first experience,
and every time since, and now every dive,
every time I put my face
in the water I'm aware
that every fish is different
from every other one,
and if a fish came sailing
through this room right now
and looked around, they'd probably think
that all people look alike,
and that's the attitude
that I had about sardines, or grouper,
or even you know squid.
You see a big flock of
them, a group of them
and they do look pretty much alike,
and then when you spend time with them,
quality time, like day and
night, get to know individuals.
You realize they have different faces,
different behaviors, different attitudes.
You can tell them apart.
Every person on the planet,
whoever has been, is now,
or ever will be is different.
Every cat, every dog, I
know it about every cat.
You know for sure, but it's such a,
I mean why is it taking
us so long to realize
that every sardine is its own self,
different from every other one,
with its own little DNA fingerprint.
It's a revelation, coupled with
a revelation new in my time,
that the connectivity, the DNA, the RNA,
the chemistry of life
through all forms of life
is remarkably similar.
That each of us shares so much in common
with every cat, every pine
tree, every jellyfish.
That's the miracle of life.
The great diversity, infinite diversity,
and a great common ground we all share.
That puts us as part of the system.
It's all connected.
No two parrot fish that look exactly alike
with freckles on their
nose, or speckled rays,
or spotted little trunk
fish, or angel fish,
of you name it.
Now we know.
Now that we know there's no excuse anymore
for continuing to behave toward the ocean
as if it's just a place to take
stuff out and put things in.
We need to understand and
respect the ocean with new eyes,
new understanding, and new policies,
new ways that are not
just good for the fish
and the reefs of the ocean,
the whales and whatever,
but it's really important to us.
So extracting wildlife
from the sea using trawls
that scrape the sea floor
like bulldozers catching
songbirds using, in a forest.
Scrape them up and shake out
the forest, throw it away,
and take a few pounds of protein.
We're destroying much of the
ocean with these heavy duty
damaging techniques that 50 years ago,
40 years ago, even 25 years ago,
maybe there was some excuse
because we didn't know
what we now know, how
vulnerable the ocean is
to our actions.
You know I love the policies
that have been developed
over recent times to look
at Mars, our sister planet,
and other places, and
thinking about what we can do
to terraform other parts
of the solar system,
especially Mars, and yet
you look in our back yard
and we're kind of doing the reverse.
We're not, I mean while we're
looking to terraform Mars,
make it more earthlike,
we're Marsiforming earth,
making it more, well
making it less hospitable,
more like our sister planet
through transformation
of the carpet of life
that keeps us alive into something that,
yeah it's okay to farm.
We need to do that to grow the food.
In 1800 it was a billion.
When I came along it was two billion,
1980, four billion,
now it's seven billion,
and the numbers go up
but the planet doesn't get any bigger.
But we can't just do to the entire planet
what we've done to a big chunk of it,
transform the natural
systems that keep us alive,
into something else.
We need to get better,
smarter, more efficient,
more effective about using the assets,
instead of burning
through the assets as if
it's all about us, all about now,
if we want to have a future for humankind.
The way we extract wildlife from the sea,
like this trawl that takes orange roughy
from 2,000 feet beneath the surface
in the southern hemisphere and market
it right here in Oakland.
In Berkeley, I think last week,
orange roughy sold for 8.95 a pound.
This fish the one you're seeing here,
may be a hundred years old.
It's like the rock fish
offshore in California.
They live a long time, they grow slowly.
It may take 25 or 30
years for them to mature.
We don't raise 25 year
old chickens or cows.
You know we like to turn
'em over pretty fast,
and yet we take wildlife from the sea,
sharks and creatures that
again live a long time,
might have taken 20 or 25 years to grow,
and yet we extract them thinking,
huh, you know they're free.
Let's just go get them,
and it's exactly what
we've been doing at a pace
that outstrips the capacity
of these creatures to recover.
Whether it's sharks, or tunas,
where is our capacity as
brilliant creatures that we are,
to think of a tuna fish
is good only in a sandwich
or in a salad, or sushi, or sashimi.
I have actually stood
next to MIT engineers,
watching them sigh with envy
at images of bluefin tuna
and other streamline fish,
while they try to figure out
how to learn from their efficiency
and capture their secrets with robo-tuna,
with creatures that might
emulate, in engineering terms,
what they do naturally.
Capturing the energy from,
as they move their tail back and forth,
little whirlpools are formed
and power them at a speed
faster then a nuclear submarine,
50 miles an hour through the water.
We don't have, with 97% efficiency
according to their calculations.
What can we learn from sperm whales,
biggest brain on the planet,
with close-knit societies,
long migrations.
They come back to areas.
Ability to hold their breath
and dive more then a mile
beneath the surface and find squid.
There's so much whales can tell us
or they can be turned into pounds of meat.
True with dolphins, we're still
in some parts of the world
just looking at dolphins
as pieces of meat.
Few countries, not all of them of course,
but it's an attitude.
Now that we know, now
that we have alternatives,
it was a different thing 10,000 years ago
when the best way we could figure out
to supply energy for ourselves
was to go out and kill wildlife,
cut the trees and all of
that, but now we know.
We should be able to
capitalize on our big brains
and figure it out.
Find a place for ourselves
within the natural systems
that keep us alive.
Figure out alternatives
to burning fossil fuels
now that we know the downside.
We know the upside, burning fossil fuels,
we went to the moon.
We couldn't do that on whale oil.
Using fossil fuels, we travel the planet
and are learning things
that we couldn't know
without burning through those assets
in the short period of
time since the middle
of the 20th century, to
give us what we now have
as the most powerful knowledge base
that the planet has ever
had available to it.
And now we know we have
to think differently
about how to power our
civilization going forward,
'cause now along with the
upside, we know the downside.
Let's use our brains.
I mean the talent is there.
The talent is in this room
to be able to measure,
and calculate, and project
where we come from,
where are we, and where are we going.
We could not have built
this graph 50 years ago,
but now we can.
This is just from 1980 to 1997,
looking at the summer ice in the Arctic.
It's a powerful picture.
It just shows the rate of change
in a little snapshot of
time that we all share.
That loss of summer ice in
the Arctic is really bad news
for walruses, and polar bears.
It's happening in the Antarctic as well.
Bad news because of the
acidification of the ocean,
with these little coccolithophords,
the foraminifera, the prochlorococcus.
Although it doesn't have
calcium carbonate shell,
prochlorococcus is said to generate
one in every five breaths we take,
and a change in the acidity of the ocean
could well effect its fate and
future, and therefore ours.
We didn't even know of
its existence before
Penny Chisholm and some
of her colleagues from MIT
on an expedition to look for phytoplankton
using a new technique,
found these ultra microscopic organisms
that are so important to
food chains in the sea,
and to powering oxygen
cycle and the carbon cycle.
What else don't we know
about the role of copepods
or the role of krill.
We do know that they're
critically important
to food chains in the sea,
but what are we doing to the ocean
that could alter their fate
and therefore modify coral reefs.
And last year, this time last year,
I think many of us were
riveted with what was happening
in the Gulf of Mexico with
the access to deep sea
that didn't exist until fairly recently,
to extract from the heart of the earth,
beneath the bottom of the ocean,
far beneath the bottom of the ocean,
a mile of water, but then
there's the rock beneath,
to access these sources of power, fuel,
that we now are using
to power our society,
and the downside that we are now putting
on the balance sheet.
There are risks, there are rewards,
but certainly there is the big reward
of using our power, now that we know,
to shape the future
based on knowing for example,
that one-time-use plastics
are kind of a stupid thing
for us to be engaged in
and yet we are doing it,
now that we know we
should change our ways.
This is a good news story,
because that little turtle
was freed from its
encumbrance and swam away.
I hope it's still out there.
But a lot of gear is
out there in the ocean,
continuing to fish,
continuing to catch and kill
some 300,000 marine mammals alone,
and hundreds of thousands
of birds are snared
in derelict fishing gear every year.
It's not just entanglement,
it's just the sheer mass
of the junk that is clogging the ocean.
This is another good news story.
Volunteers, students going out
to the Northwest Hawaiian Islands,
hoping to retrieve masses of
plastic, the fishing gear,
and taking it out of the ocean.
Another good news story,
in July of this year
I went to Hong Kong where
a thousand school kids
gathered to take the pledge.
We will protect sharks.
We will never eat shark
fin soup again or ever.
I don't think most of
them ever had tried it,
but they pledged not to.
Here in California, just a week ago,
Governor Brown signed a
legislation making it illegal
to have trade in shark fins, yahoo, yeah!
(audience applauding)
The good news, people do care,
and that's why I am a hope-aholic.
I think that armed with knowledge,
the ability to communicate together,
and disseminate information,
and to bring the community together,
not just the scientists,
not just the policy makers,
not just the artists,
not just the historians,
not just the writers, it's everybody.
I personally have a vested
interest in all of this
because I have three children.
I have four grandsons, two of them here,
and they remind me, we've gotta figure out
which way are we going, you know.
We have a choice, we do have a choice.
What do you like, the
blue one or the red one?
I like the blue.
We're edging toward the
red through our actions,
more CO2 in the
atmosphere, more like mars,
less water or water that is
not usable for us, less life.
We want to, I think, aim for this,
an enduring place for
ourselves within the systems
that keep us alive.
Well the consequence of my TED wish,
I showed this picture first
and I used the comment
that I first used when I
gave a talk at the World Bank
a couple years ago.
I said, there it is, the world bank.
That's where the assets are,
and we've been drawing them down
through the history of our species.
Now we know, we gotta
take care of the place.
We have to use those assets wisely.
It doesn't mean that
we have to stop fishing
or stop farming in places,
but we can be much wiser
about how we use the assets.
We must think about the importance
of the diversity of life
and its value to us.
I mean it's good enough for
me to save whales, or tunas,
or calamari in the, the
squids for their own sake,
for just because.
I don't know how to make them
and I don't think I should
exert my power to destroy them.
But I think the thing that
will get to most people is
well what does it matter,
why should I care?
If the ocean dried up tomorrow,
what difference would it make?
Well a lot of difference,
like if you like to breathe,
if you like to have an existence on earth.
So, one of the outcomes of
my talk, after the talk,
right after the talk, one guy came up.
He was just like a
little, almost elf-like.
He's just a really
unassuming looking person,
but he said with a great seriousness.
I think I understand.
If we fail to take care of the
ocean, nothing else matters.
The economy, security,
health, all anchors back
to taking care of the
natural world, mostly blue.
And he wrote a check
for a million dollars,
and that was the start of
Mission Blue as an organization.
It was the start of an expedition
to the Galapagos Islands
that took place a year and a half ago,
where we got about a hundred of people,
some of the best minds
that we could muster
from around the world to come together
and to give the talk of
their life. (laughing)
About 25 people actually gave talks,
the rest were there to listen
and to use what they were inspired to do,
as a consequence of hearing these talks,
and thinking about the ocean,
and to go forth and do something.
And it's resulted in a
lot of different things,
but it includes this organization that,
it's called the Sylvia Earle Alliance,
but it's a bit like Lance Armstrong.
That's the foundation.
But what is he trying to do?
Livestrong.
So it's the Sylvia Earle
Alliance, that's the foundation.
What we're tryin' to do
is to just build momentum
of the Mission Blue.
It's to get people to use their talents,
use their capacity in whatever
way they are inspired to do,
to make a difference for the ocean.
It's a loose network of
organizations, of individuals,
of anybody, everybody
to sign up to the idea
that it's our mission to
take care of the place.
And poets can join in,
scientists can do it, kids,
CEO's, presidents of companies,
or corporations, or countries.
Anybody and everyone
can do what they can do.
I want to just share
with you a little glimpse
of what happened when we went to sea.
It's a little video clip.
It's a trailer actually for
a film that will come out,
first at Sundance this Spring,
and then it will be in
theaters I hope following that.
It's a little heavy on what
they say about Sylvia Earle.
They should say more about the ocean,
but it's a glimpse anyway of,
to catch the idea of
what actually happened.
(gentle droning music)
50 years ago
when I began exploring the ocean,
it seemed at that time
to be a sea of Eden,
but now we know.
We are now facing paradise lost.
- This trip is absolutely
brand new for TED,
we've never done anything like it before.
The trip came about because of a wish
that TED granted Sylvia Earle.
- I hope for your help to explore
and protect the wild ocean
in ways that will restore the health,
and in so doing secure hope for humankind.
- Sylvia Earle has devoted her life
to this passion of the oceans.
- And the need for
knowledge about all aspects
of the environment, whether
on the land or on the sea.
I've always been a scientist.
I am a scientist, but I've
been transformed in part
I suppose by having children
and seeing that the
places I knew as a child,
I can't take them, because they're gone.
- [Chris] Trip is a bet,
that if you bring together
a group of really remarkable
people who are well resourced,
some of the world's
greatest marine scientists,
some of the world's great storytellers.
You put them together and you show them
what's happening in the oceans,
something incredible is gonna happen.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- I was raised with a
great respect for nature,
but I'd never added the ocean to that.
And to be able to be in a
place like the Galapagos,
to actually get into the water
and see some of the creatures
that we're talking about
has changed my life.
- Getting people to not only
understand intellectually,
but to know their hearts.
We're so changing the way the world works
that our future is at risk.
- The type of fishing going on today
is really wiping bluefin
ecologically off the planet.
- Whale meat being sold in these markets
was really dolphin meat and it was toxic.
- There's around a hundred
million sharks caught every year,
so this is a truly global problem.
- We're literally sucking like a straw,
life right out of this planet.
- And so the idea of Hope Spots,
the idea of protected areas
is like whoa, you know.
But it's gotta be big,
and it's gotta be real,
and you gotta have people
with guns out there
to protect it, because it sure as hell
isn't gonna be protected
by wishful thinking
or let's all go off and sing Kum ba yah.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- But if wait another 50 years
or even another 10 years,
things we can do now will be gone.
- There is no more tomorrow
that we can avoid confronting.
- [Newscaster] Bobby Jindal has declared
a state of emergency because of the spill.
- [Man] What's at stake
for the environment
is the oil begins to touch land.
- And to me, crude oil
ain't nuttin' but the devil.
- Man is destroyin' the planet.
- Just like the Bible
says, in greed and time
you will destroy your own earth,
and that's what's happenin'.
- Scientists in Mississippi
are trying to gauge the impact
of the spill as it starts to
spread into the prime habitat
of the biggest fish in the gulf.
- These animals are here
to feed during this time
and this oil spill is
right in their backyard.
- But they're on death row.
If for nothing else good
comes of this major spill,
it may be to wake up people to say
we have to protect the Gulf.
- [Man] There are real issues
here of money, and power.
- It's life itself that
the ocean is delivering
and we have been abusing the ocean.
We haven't been caring for the ocean.
- Why don't we write to
a hundred world leaders?
- There must be someplace
where these forests
of unique creatures can be safe.
- [Man] And Sylvia's timing is
perfect, this is that moment.
- The government is onboard.
- And this bill is not only,
we've heard it's the first
in the United States,
this is the first in the world.
- [Sylvia] We're a hundred miles offshore
in the Gulf of Mexico.
- On corals, you're just
looking at brown gunky stuff.
- [Sylvia] A great grand
finale for this version
of the Alvin, we need every bit
of insight that we can muster.
(dramatic rhythmic music)
The ocean is alive.
Without the ocean, life on
earth simply would not exist.
- [Woman] I do not wanna envision a world
for our grandchildren
and great-grandchildren
that doesn't have Orcas,
that doesn't have hammerhead sharks,
because we're all connected.
- [Scientist] I'm here
because Sylvia Earle
is one of the most
remarkable women on earth.
- [Man] She's the real thing.
She's a person who has committed herself
and everything that
that commitment implies,
and we need more of that.
- We have the capacity
to protect the systems
that keep us alive.
We still have a chance,
but now's the time.
So this is the time, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Chris] Hi my name is Chris Pensetitch,
and I work at the Turtle
Island Restoration Network.
- Great.
- [Chris] So there's a group
of people that live very close
to the ocean, that care
very deeply about the ocean,
that drag giant bulldozers
across the Gulf of Mexico,
sweeping down everything in their path,
the shrimp trawl fishermen.
How do we communicate to
them that this livelihood
that they care so much about is something
that is while profitable,
causing huge devastation
to the Gulf of Mexico ecosystem?
- It's a tough question but,
one answer that I wish
I could snap my fingers
and make happen is to take them down
to see what it's like.
It's transformative, actually
out there in the Gulf where,
what I was, with the whale
sharks, diving with them,
it was actually a charter fishing boat.
This was just sports fishing,
but the crew consisted
of individuals who were
commercial fishermen,
and the one, when he saw
us jumping in the water,
getting the,
he wasn't intending to
get in the water with me,
but he couldn't resist it.
So he jumped in, grabbed
a pair of fins and snorkel
and he went in the water, and,
the filmmakers involved
interviewed him afterwards,
I hope this comes through in
the final cut of the film.
Because he just gets this
faraway look in his face
and he talks about how
he thought he could hear
the heart beating of this big fish,
and he'd never been in the
water with the fish before,
never done it.
But we were all doing it and
the big fish were right there.
He just couldn't stand it.
If I had a submarine available
to take people down to just look.
People who eat the shrimp
are a part of the problem.
You love popcorn shrimp,
give it up. (laughing)
Shrimp cocktail, it's too
expensive no matter how little
or how much you pay for it.
The real price of it
is just not there for you to see.
It's written in the,
Monterey Aquarium had a wonderful exhibit,
not now but recently,
it was a few years ago.
They had this portrayal
of a crystal goblet
with shrimp, like a half dozen shrimp,
big juicy ones all around,
and around it was this halo
of life that had been
killed in the process
of getting those six shrimp.
I mean the ratio is
conservatively five to one.
I've been onboard shrimp boats,
it's more like a hundred
to one, sometimes more.
If you've seen Forrest Gump, (laughing)
here's the trawler, goes
across the ocean floor,
Brook dumps it out on the deck,
turtles included.
I didn't see any in Forrest Gump,
but that's how a lot of turtles die,
or the nets that are left,
some of the turtles are
drowned because the trawls
drag for quite a while on the bottom,
long enough to drown the turtles.
Anyway, it's just disgraceful
that we know this exists
and we just go on business as usual.
Long lines, another great
source of killing turtles.
Knowing is got to be the answer.
It's the key, if you
don't know you can't care,
and most of those who are in the business,
especially the large-scale,
industrial-scale extraction
of ocean wildlife, like
menhaden from the Gulf of Mexico
and the Chesapeake Bay, and
along the Eastern Seaboard.
It's the filtration
system for those areas,
along with sponges, and
oysters, and clams, and such,
and it's part of the food chain.
It's part of what makes the ocean work.
And we can get away with taking a few,
but we can't do it on
the scale that we're now,
or using the techniques
that we're now imposing.
So I don't know a straight
answer to your question.
Short question, he did his job,
long answer, sorry about that.
But it takes some real thinking
and ideas that you might have.
It's not the fisherman's fault.
They thought when they started,
hey this is what we do.
Nobody thought that there was any problem
with killing all these starfish,
and other things that are
dragged up from the ocean floor.
But the fishermen do know,
you know I did spend some time,
I spent a lot of time around the Gulf
and just a few weeks ago I
was up in Martha's Vineyard,
the center of the universe
for early whaling.
You know they've seen the transition.
Whaling, cod, and now
you know, but they're,
I think small scale local fishing,
sensitive to having an enduring place
within the system could work, might work,
but whatever it is has to be coupled
with large-scale protected areas
where you leave the system alone.
If you want to have birds,
you can't just slaughter
them on a wholesale basis.
We did that with passenger pigeons,
and the Carolina parakeets,
and Eskimo curlews.
We know how to exterminate the
great aux, we've done that.
What we don't have clearly a vision for,
is how do we keep these
creatures as a part
of what keeps us alive.
We need to start at the earliest age
to get kids locked in to
that as a mission in life.
The fishermen in the Gulf,
the kids aren't looking to that as a way
to make a living, they're not.
They can't, it's not much of a living now.
- [Ed] Ed Almanzo with
Laguna Ocean Foundation.
I wonder if you might say something
about how these Hope Spots are selected.
- How are the Hope Spots selected?
Well, it's like open
season for Hope Spots.
A colleague of mine, a
fellow explorer in residence
at the National Geographic, Enric Sala,
who was at Scripps for 10 years,
and really focused on
pristine areas to protect.
And I really whole heartedly endorse that,
find those places that
are still in great shape
and do everything you can to
not let them be destroyed,
like Raja Ampat out in
the Western Pacific,
like the Northwest Hawaiian Islands
still in pretty good shape.
Looking at the deep
reefs almost everywhere,
in the high seas, there's
still reason for hope
that if we act now we can
maintain the integrity,
and they'll help restore some of the areas
that have been diminished.
So using the new techniques
that are out there,
high-diversity is one
measure, water quality.
Another measure is how realistic is it?
Is there any possibility
that you can actually make this happen?
Good news, just last year,
this year, this year, earlier this year,
the UK has declared the
biggest fully protected area
in the ocean, half a
million square kilometers
around the Chagos Archipelago
in the Indian Ocean.
Beautiful coral reefs, no fishing allowed.
I have a small sea story
about the Northwest Hawaiian Islands,
about how that was selected,
took about 10 years of people
building a database, making
a case for why this matters.
There's the monk seal,
that's their primary habitat,
and there are only about a thousand
of them left in the world.
So either you take action to protect them
or we gonna see them go
the way of the monk seal
that was in the Gulf of
Mexico and the Caribbean.
The last one seen in 1952,
they're gone, all gone.
So Jean-Michel Cousteau did a film
about the Northwest Hawaiian Islands,
a series of films actually, four films,
and Laura Bush, a unlikely
person one might think,
but she does really care about nature
and she made a trip out to
the Northwest Hawaiian Islands
to Midway, was just appalled at the mass
of plastic out there, seeing
those poor albatrosses
just stuffed, the babies
dead, plastic spilled out
all over the ground.
So one thing led to another
and she invited Jean-Michel
to come to the White
House and show his film.
And a little list of 50
people were selected,
I got to be one of the
lucky ducks to be invited,
and nobody really expected
that she would show up, but she did,
and more then that, so did George.
And must have been a
quiet week in Washington
or on the planet as a whole,
because they both came,
and we watched the film,
had popcorn, drank sodas,
and then we're invited to dinner
in a room about this large
with tables for six people, and each of,
they all set up.
We went through a line to fill our plates
and I had invited a guest who sat,
it was a little ahead of me in the line,
she sat at the table, and
this guy came and asked
if he could sit next to her
and it was the President
of the United States.
And so she said yes he could sit with her,
and then Jean-Michel
came and sat next to him,
that was his rightful place,
and then the head of the
Marine Sanctuary Program,
Lori Arguelles, Foundation,
and her husband.
And there's one seat left
and I started walking toward my friend,
and then I saw who she was with,
and then started to back
off 'cause I didn't think,
you know, I'm just a guest here.
This is, but my feet kept going anyway
and I took my place and
we had an hour and a half
over dinner, without any
watchers or anything.
We just, we talked fish.
And I remember hearing myself saying,
because Bush likes to fish,
that if there are to be fishermen,
you've gotta have fish, duh.
And if you are to have
fish you have to protect
the places that they live,
breeding areas, feeding areas.
They have to have space.
We can't take them anywhere
in any numbers at any time,
and that's what we've been
doing to fish, and that's why.
He didn't know that 90% of
many of the big fish are gone.
He didn't know that less
then 1% of the ocean
was really protected, at that
time it was less then 1%.
Because of the 10 years
invested in making a case,
and people, individuals and
organizations making a case,
it was kind of an easy nudge,
but it was still unexpected,
that when he left that night,
he called over to the group,
to Jim Connaughton, who's
the head of the CEQ,
"Jim, I want you to make it happen.
"This should be the biggest area",
they had three sizes,
small, medium, and large,
he said, "We want the biggest
area and want it to be
"no take, no fishing.
"You got that Jim?"
Everybody was swept away.
We thought it was going
to be another place
like the Monterey Bay Marine Sanctuary
that is a managed area.
Where fishing would be fine, you just,
you know you declare it a sanctuary,
but you let things go on
pretty much business as usual,
with some constraints,
and certainly the idea
that you would educate
people to care for the place,
but no he said no take.
To make it happen, meant Jim Connaughton
went off in a huddle and
resurrected the technique
that Teddy Roosevelt used to establish
some of the biggest and best
National Parks in the country,
and that is the Antiquities
Act that made it possible
to declare a monument,
that isn't a sanctuary,
it's a monument.
So the President by
Presidential decree could say,
it's 240,000, no it's 340,000
square miles of ocean.
I'm sorry for the
Northwest Hawaiian Islands,
140,000 square miles of ocean,
at the time the biggest marine
protected area in the world
by the not so green President,
he's certainly blue.
Because the Northwest Hawaiian Islands
Marine National Monument is bigger
then all the National Parks put together,
and the fish are safe there.
It takes some enforcement,
as Jeremy Jackson said, you know,
"You gotta go out there with guns."
And there are some problems,
but the fact is that
that started this big is somethin',
and in Kiribati in the Western Pacific,
they have 200 miles surrounding
their little speck of islands.
They've established even a
larger marine protected area
and then came the UK with
the Chagos Archipelago,
and then Chile, again Enric Sala
had something to do with this,
a little speck of rock in the
ocean called Salas y Gomez,
that now is fully protected
in the waters around it,
one of the biggest marine protected areas.
So the needle is moving.
It was less then 1% and now
it's slightly more then 1%,
and now there are people who are saying
we need 20% by 2020, woo-hoo.
You know, maybe we can get there.
I don't know, any, every
inch, every drop counts,
and that's how you do it, any way you can.
- [William] Please join
me in thanking Dr. Earle
for a wonderful, informative presentation.
(audience applauding)
- [Sylvia] Thank you.
(gentle electronic keyboard music)